SPEAKER: We are super excited to
bring Trisha Ocona Francis back
to Google to speak
with you guys.
She may be a familiar
face to some of you.
She actually came and did
a really, really great talk
at Google last year,
which was so popular
and got so many rave reviews
that we had to have her back.
So we're super excited to
have her back again today.
For some of you guys
that may not yet
be familiar with Trisha,
I'll tell you guys
just a little bit about her.
So she is the CEO of
realestateOCONA LLC.
And she's super active
in her community.
She's quickly become
a o-to resource
that many community
members seek out
when looking for advice
about real estate
because she has such
great expertise.
She's won and been recognized
by top awards such as NY1 news
NYer of the Week, 2012
Extraordinary Women
of Brooklyn, and 2014
Rising Star of Brooklyn.
Also, outside the
walls of her own firm,
she's also super active
and wears many hats.
Trisha also sits on the board
of the New York State Department
of Real Estate.
She's an instructor at Medgar
Evers College, a real estate
blogger for the Huffington
Post business section,
and she's appeared on top
radio and news publications,
including Hot 97 Street Soldiers
with Lisa Evers and ABC7's Here
and Now with Sandra Bookman.
So we're super excited
to have her here.
She's going to share some
stuff that she prepared
to talk with you guys about.
We're going to try to
leave about 10 minutes
at the end for questions.
So you guys feel free to
think through anything
that you're going to ask her.
And we can leave time
for that at the end.
And without further ado,
I'll pass it on to Trisha.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS:
Thank you so much.
Thank you to you and
[INAUDIBLE] Davidson,
Terrence Copney for putting
this together for me.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for having me back.
I know last time we came and
we spoke about real estate
and how important it is.
And now I'm here to
talk about foreclosures.
Many of you may
not know, but there
are 30,000 people facing
foreclosure, unfortunately,
in New York City.
And that's 30,000
people who possibly
can be losing their home.
But when there's negative,
there's also positive.
How can we take advantage of
those people who have to sell,
those people who are
going into the auctions.
How can we purchase those
homes at great prices.
And that's what I'm
here to talk about--
how can we get into
investment, how
do you get into
foreclosure investment
and avoid foreclosure yourself,
or get that really good deal.
That's a question that
I'm asked so often.
And that's what I'm
here to help you with.
Now, I know we already
went into this.
So I'm not going to
go further into it.
But I just wanted
to let you know
that, in addition to teaching
real estate at Medger Evers
College, I do have my own
real estate brokerage firm.
I'm located downtown
Brooklyn in Cadman Plaza.
I'm actually on the 12th floor.
Hillary Clinton campaign's
office is on the 11th floor.
And just because I'm in
Brooklyn doesn't mean
I do Brooklyn, just Brooklyn.
I also do New Jersey.
I do a whole lot of
the Tri-State area.
And I sit on the New York
State Real Estate Board
where I'm appointed by the
governor and the speaker.
And I'm one of the five
brokers in the whole state
of New York that
helps make the rules
and regulations that real
estate agents have to follow.
So between sitting on this
board where we meet four times
a year in Albany to discuss
the rules and teaching,
there's a lot of insight
that I have that I'm here
to share it with you.
Now, why do I do this?
I put my information
out there because I
know 30,000 people in
foreclosure, we want to invest.
We have money.
Real estate is
something that's always
been around which we'll go to.
How do I invest in real estate
and get most for my money
and actually come
into the game of it?
So I just enjoy helping people
achieve their real estate
goals.
That's basically what it is.
Many of you want to
get into it and want
to know, how do I get started,
where do I put my money.
You have to understand that real
estate is the number one asset.
Everybody wants to get into it.
And everything is real estate.
That's the first part
I want to get into
is for you to look
at it and say, wow,
every single thing
is real estate.
This building that we are in
is a piece of real estate.
Right?
The parking lot, the school
building, courthouses,
houses that you live
in, it's real estate.
And real estate has
always been around.
So sometimes you put
money-- I have money
in the stock market as well.
But real estate is something
that has always been around
and will always be around.
So how do we jump in?
How do we be a part of it?
How do we take
part of the action,
especially with so many
foreclosures happening?
If you look at this,
in the year 2020,
which product do you
think will hold its value
or appreciate for somebody
who buys it today?
Is it a car?
Is it a building?
Or is it sneakers?
Absolutely the building.
So we invest into the building.
On my block where
I live in Brooklyn,
there are people who bought
their home for $30,000.
We can buy homes
with $30,000 cash.
And now, these buildings
are going for over $400,000,
sometimes half a million dollars
from buying it for $30,000.
So why aren't we
jumping into this?
OK, so what are we
going to learn today?
The first thing I
want to teach you
is to establish an
agency relationship
with the proper professionals.
You want to build a
team when you're going
to buy a foreclosure homes.
You can't jump into it.
You have to have a lawyer.
You have to have a real estate
agent, broker, professional who
is working for your side.
So how do you get that
agency to make sure
that that professional
is working
for you and not the other side?
You also have to want
to be ready to buy.
Right?
How do we prepare ourselves
to buy foreclosures?
Be ready to negotiate.
Just because it's a
foreclosure, we're
going to understand what does
a foreclosure really mean.
You have to be ready
to negotiate this deal
and not just take
what they give you
and understand what you want.
You have to know the rules
and how to play by them.
OK?
Just because someone
says it's a foreclosure,
you have to understand
the city, the state rules,
the federal rules,
and understand
that what I'm getting into is
what I'm getting into and not
listening to just
everything people tell you.
That's the problem.
Like I said, I sit on this
the board and I teach it.
So sometimes people
even come to me
when I'm working for someone
who's looking to purchase,
and I say, that's not the rule.
I'm not going to be here
to get myself in trouble.
I want to buy, and
I want to buy right.
OK?
Also, beware of
your expectations.
Sometimes, people
have expectations
that are far beyond
what is realistic.
Right?
They'll come in, and
they'll say, hey, I
have heard silly, silly stuff.
I have $10,000 and I want a five
bedroom house with a four car
garage.
And I'm like, not
always what it is.
OK?
And also limit your risk.
When you jump into foreclosures
and real estate buying,
you want to be careful.
You're putting in
a lot of money.
You're putting in a lot of
money to buy these homes.
And you have to make sure
that you're analyzing it right
or you have a professional who
is able to analyze it right,
identify what's right,
and evaluate the property.
Just because the property
is going for $10,000
doesn't mean that this
is the right property.
You also want to look at
what's going on in the area.
Right?
What's happening?
We could all understand
that the Barclay Center that
came into downtown Brooklyn,
if you bought property
in that area, your
money went up.
So you want to know what's
going on in that area that's
going to increase it.
And know your endgame.
Just because you're
buying a property--
some people buy a property
like I said, $10,000.
Oh, I have a great
property for $10,000.
That doesn't mean
it's a great property.
What are you going to do
when you get this property?
What is your goal?
And we'll talk about
some of those things.
In a foreclosure, what is
often considered the hardest
consequence for a homeowner?
Now, you may say to yourself,
Trisha, I'm here to buy.
I'm not the homeowner
going in foreclosure.
Well, you have to
understand this
because when you're
buying a foreclosure,
you want to know what
happened to that property.
That's something that
I do all the time.
When I'm helping a purchaser
purchase a property,
I'm researching that property.
I want to know why did they
lose that property, what's
happening, because I want to
make sure none of that happens
to me or their issues don't fall
back on this property with me.
So in a foreclosure,
what is often
considered the hardest
consequence for a homeowner?
Damage of their credit,
deficiency judgment,
or losing their home.
Well, we're going to think about
that and come back to it later.
And excuse me if I sit down
for just a little while.
We're going to go over a
few of the terminology.
Deficiency judgment--
anybody knows
what that means when it
comes to real estate?
Well, let me explain to you
what deficiency judgment is.
If you purchased a home and you
take out a loan for $500,000
and then you cannot
pay that loan--
a homeowner takes out
a loan for $500,000.
They cannot pay that loan.
And they go delinquent
in their loan.
And they say, you know what?
I have to sell this
house now because I
can't afford this home anymore.
The market of that property
may have gone down.
Maybe they bought
that house overpriced,
or maybe the condition of
the home has gone down.
So sometimes, when you're
getting foreclosures,
the condition of the home
is not always the best
because if someone is unable
to pay their mortgage loan,
then they probably could
not upkeep the house.
So maybe the roof went bad,
maybe the plumbing, maybe
the electrical.
So the value went down.
So even though they have a
loan on this home for $500,000,
the house is now worth $400,000.
So no one is going to buy
this home for the $500,000.
They're going to buy it for
the $400,000 that it's worth.
Well, they sell this home
for $400,000 in agreement
with the bank.
What do you think
happens to that $100,000?
Well, what happens is it can
turn to a deficiency judgment
where this homeowner is
owed that money later.
And it's turned into a
judgment against them.
May not.
They can negotiate it sometimes.
But sometimes, they owe
this money later on.
And now you, as the
purchaser of this home,
you may not think
that's your problem.
But you may want
to think about it.
This is something I
always tell purchasers.
You want to think about
it because you don't want
any law-- I'm not an attorney.
But you don't want any
lawsuits to come back later
where they say, I didn't
know I was going to get
this deficiency judgment.
I want my house back, or
I want you to pay for it.
So this is something
that you want
to talk about with
the professional
that you're working
with, with your attorney,
with your broker to make
sure all of that is handled.
An acceleration clause
or an alienation clause--
when someone takes out
a loan and a mortgage,
a lot of times people say, I
am going to take a mortgage.
Right?
And you know, this terminology
that I go through with you,
if I ever speak to
you individually,
I like to educate people
first because I'm an educator.
I teach real estate
at the college.
And I take people
through the steps.
I truly believe
that more you know,
the better it is for you
to purchase your house.
A lot of real estate
brokers don't like
to teach you this information.
They want you to go in blindly.
Well, that's why we have 30,000
people facing foreclosure.
But if you understand
this before you purchase,
you'll be a better buyer
when you buy your home.
When you buy a home, if
you take out a loan--
some people buy cash.
Some people use a loan.
If you take out a loan and
you're getting a mortgage,
you are not getting a mortgage.
You are giving a mortgage.
That's the terminology
that really irritates me
because you're not
getting a mortgage,
you're giving a mortgage because
the definition of "mortgage"
is collateral.
You're giving the
bank permission,
as a voluntary lien, that
if I do not pay my loan,
if I default, I'm
giving you permission
to take my house back.
That's why you are the one
giving the bank the mortgage.
But when you go-- if anyone
here owns a home, when
you buy a house
and you're sitting
at the closing, how big are
those papers you have to sign?
Like this thick, right?
You're signing and
signing and signing.
And you're not even
reading those papers.
Well, within those papers,
in those mortgage papers,
there is something called
an acceleration clause.
An acceleration
cause is something
that allows a bank
to go to court
and take back the house
if you don't follow.
The most common way for a
bank to foreclose on you
is not paying.
But that's not the only way.
A lot of people don't know
that's not the only way
that a bank can
foreclose in your house
and accelerate the clause.
If you don't pay your taxes,
you've defaulted on the loan.
If you don't upkeep the house,
If you've changed or
altered the house,
you've defaulted on the loan.
Because think about it.
If you buy a house and
it's a three bedroom
and you change it
into a two bedroom,
you've defaulted on
the loan because you've
changed the house without
the bank's approval.
You may have gone to the
county and gotten approval
from the county.
But you have not asked
the bank permission
because the resale
on a three bedroom
is a lot higher than a
resale of a two bedroom.
So you've changed the value.
So by not asking the
bank's permission,
you have triggered the
acceleration clause.
Another cause on it,
not paying your taxes.
But there's an
alienation clause.
Sometimes, you have people who
are in trouble with the IRS
or child support
or whatever reason.
And they want to get their name
off that title, off the deed.
And they will take their
name off the title.
They will sign it over
to a cousin or a daughter
or a sister or a brother and
remove their name off the deed.
But their name is still
on the mortgage papers.
You have alienated
yourself off that property.
And that is a reason for the
bank to foreclose on you.
You have recourse or
non-recourse loans,
when you personally
guarantee these loans
and they can come for you.
You have mortgage
assignments, where
you can assign the
mortgage to someone else.
And then you have
right to redemption.
New York State does not
have right to redemption.
Every state is different.
And I can go personally
with you in that state.
You have to know
also where you're
buying a property
because if you are
a homeowner-- in some
states, when you foreclose,
I know people who are in
foreclosure for five years.
And that's because the
bank is so backlogged
and the court system is so
backlogged that they haven't
been able to get to this person,
this homeowner yet, to actually
lose the home,
whereas some states,
you go into foreclosure,
two months later,
you've lost your home.
Well, right to
redemption just says,
once you are at the
auction and they
hit the auction and the house
is gone, you can't get it back.
In some states, they give
the homeowner a couple days
after to come back and
get the house back.
Maybe they've borrowed the
money, won the lottery,
or whatever the case is.
They can get the house back.
So these are just
a few terminologies
that I think that
anyone who is looking
to invest in foreclosures should
understand because you have
to understand, this person
was buying the house before,
who owned the home before.
And now they're losing the
and when you're taking it.
OK, what is foreclosure?
This is a lot of information.
So I'm trying to get
through all of it
because I really want to get
to the meat and potatoes.
There is a huge difference
between foreclosure
and pre-foreclosure.
People come to me all
the time-- Trisha,
I want to buy a foreclosure.
Well, guess what?
If a homeowner is behind
on their mortgage payments,
you can't get that
home from them
unless they're
willing to sell it.
Until someone actually loses
their home in the auction,
you can't just take
their home from them.
They have to be willing to work
with you and sell it to you.
So there's a huge difference
between foreclosures
and pre-foreclosures.
Someone who has
missed their payments,
they can be in pre-foreclosure.
Someone who has totally
lost their home to a bank
and has not paid
it and the bank has
gone through the court system,
that is a foreclosed home.
What does foreclosure
look like today?
I remember, when I
started real estate--
I started real
estate 16 years ago.
Foreclosures were homes
that were boarded up.
Right?
They were just the grass and
weeds were growing outside.
This is basically what
foreclosures looked like when
I started real estate.
Not anymore.
With 30,000 people
in foreclosure,
you're looking at foreclosures
that are looking like this.
You have sometimes
15-unit buildings,
regular houses with pools.
You're hearing
celebrities are losing
their mansions to foreclosures.
So you can pick up
some pretty nice houses
for a much lower prices
that are foreclosures
and that look great.
You have shopping centers, malls
that are going to foreclosures.
Now, let's just go through
quickly the process
of foreclosure.
When you own a home--
because we still
want to get into the
mindset of this homeowner
because if we're buying this
home from this homeowner,
we have to understand
what are we
getting into before we put
our money into this home.
When you have a house, your
mortgage is due on the first.
They give you a
15-day grace period.
For all of those who
do not own a home,
your home is due on the first.
By the 15th, if it's not
paid, it's considered late.
By the 30th, just
like a credit card,
that's when you will have it
reported to your credit bureau
that you've missed your payment.
After-- it could be anywhere
between 90 days and five
months, the lender can
start a lawsuit with you.
And it's called a lis
pendens because by then, you
have defaulted on your
mortgage payments.
And they're going
to come after you.
The owner has to give
a response as to why.
The owner has time
to make the payments.
The court goes through
their decision.
The owner sometimes
can appeal it.
But at that point,
if it doesn't work,
then the court goes
for an auction.
We're in Manhattan.
In all five boroughs
in New York City,
there is an auction every
single week in a courthouse.
In Brooklyn, it's
on Adams Street.
They have a website for it.
What you can do is you
can look up the homes that
are going through auction.
When I first started
real estate 16 years ago,
there was about three homes
being auctioned a week.
Now, there's about 30 homes
These are homes where they
have gone through the process,
the court system.
And now, they're being lost.
And they're being auctioned
off in the courthouse.
If someone is buying the
homes in the auction,
the buyer goes to
the auction and bids.
They have to put down
a deposit and come back
within a certain amount of
time to pay for the difference.
The problem with the
auction, a lot of the houses
are underwater.
They're upside down, which means
that they're worth $400,000
but the mortgage
balance is $500,000.
You may not want to buy
a home in that situation.
Plus, they tack
on attorney fees.
So sometimes, the auction
is maybe not always
the best place to go.
But it's good to experience.
Sometimes, you can get it.
You just have to
research the homes.
OK?
Some states, we have
a right to redemption.
OK, now, once the home
is not sold at auction,
it goes back to the bank.
The bank then takes it as
an REO, Real Estate Owned.
That's when the bank
takes that property.
They do an appraisal
on the property.
And they prepare it to sell.
If a homeowner is
living in that home,
they will evict the homeowner.
The homeowner no
longer owns that home.
If it's a multi-family property,
the homeowner no longer
has a right to collect rent
because they no longer own
that property.
Now, you as an investor
can purchase that property
through the bank.
And they're not selling it for
what the homeowner owed for it.
They're selling it now
for a reduced price
because they've done
an appraisal on it,
they've spoken to
their investors that
owned that note on that home,
and now, they're selling it.
So you would get in contact
with a mortgage broker
to see that home and
to purchase that home.
If that home is not
sold through an REO,
it can become an HUD home.
There is a HUD key.
I have a HUD key.
The HUD key is a master
key that opens up every HUD
home in the whole country.
And you can see that home.
And you can bid on that home.
Now, some homes are
for first-time buyers.
Some homes are for a nonprofits.
Some homes are for investors.
Some homes are for anyone.
They will categorize that.
You have to keep in mind that
sometimes these homes need
work.
So you have to go in
there and assess the work.
Remember, I told you
about building your team?
You want to have a
real estate broker.
You want to have an attorney.
You more than likely
want to have someone
who's a contractor that
can help you go in there
and do some of the work.
Sometimes, the house
just needs appliances.
OK?
So I have a friend who
just purchased two homes,
not in this state.
He paid $25,000 for each home.
He got a loan on the home.
The loan was $150 a month.
The rental income
is $800 a month.
And what is he going to do?
He's going to rent the home out.
All the home needs
is appliances.
And that is passive
income every single month.
And he has a property.
What are other options
for the homeowner
for them not to lose their home?
Why do I go through this even
though you want to invest?
Because when you speak
to these homeowners
or you speak to the
broker, you want
to know what
happened to the home.
Why did they lose the home?
There are many options.
There is something
called a short sale.
There is a deed in lieu.
Deed in lieu is basically
where you are foreclosing--
you're a homeowner.
And you're foreclosing
on this home.
You can't afford
this home anymore.
You turn to the
bank, and you say,
I would like to give
you the home back.
They also call it
giving back the keys.
And some people,
very silly, will
put the keys in an envelope
and mail it to the bank.
It doesn't work like that.
You call the bank.
They would do that.
You call the bank, and you
negotiate with the bank
and say, hey, I want to
give back this house.
I can't afford it.
And the bank will
draft the papers.
And then you you will sign
the deed back over to them.
It's very rare for banks to
do that because banks are not
in the house business.
They're in the money business.
They don't want to keep a house
because just think about it.
That boarded up
house that you see
when you go home, that's
a liability to someone.
When a house is boarded
up, you have the risk
of having prostitution in there,
crime in there, drugs in there,
murders in there.
The pipes can freeze.
Who's sweeping the leaves?
Who's shoveling the snow?
The bank rather has
the homeowner in there
until they can sell it.
So they don't really like
to do the deed and lieus.
A homeowner can sell a home.
If they know they're
facing foreclosure
and are unable to
make their payments,
they can sell their home.
I have sold many homes of people
who are facing foreclosure.
And we sold it just in time.
The advantage as an investor
is if the broker is selling
a home that is
facing foreclosure,
you can get it
cheaper, possibly,
than what they would
normally sell it
for because the clock is
ticking with them before there's
an auction.
So if the person owes
$400,000 on his house
and this house is
worth $600,000,
they can't probably get $600,000
if the clock is ticking.
Maybe you can give
them $550,000.
Maybe you can give them
$500,000 because they
have to do it in a quick sale.
Not always, but
sometimes they can.
Sometimes, the
homeowner can refinance.
But that's a little
tough as well
because if they
miss payments, then
that means they've already
damaged their credit.
So a bank may not
refinance with them.
But the other thing that
I want you to hear about
is short sales.
I'm sure many of you have
heard of short sales and said,
hmm, short sales may
be the way for me
to get into a foreclosed home.
Well, basically, a
short sale-- the example
I gave you before, a homeowner
owes $500,000 on their house.
But the market and
condition of their property
says it's only worth
about $400,000.
So they put this house on
the market for $500,000
because they owe $500,000.
Maybe they put it for
$550,000 because there's
fees they have to pay.
It's not getting sold.
No one's buying it.
Who's going to buy a house
for $550,000 when it's worth
$400,000.
So what they do is
they bring it down.
And they're getting
offers now at $400,000.
But, hey, remember that
deficiency judgment.
They can't sell the
house for $400,000
when they owe $550,000 on it.
So what they're doing is they're
going to do a short sale where
they're asking the
bank if they can
take $400,000 for this house.
Please, I know I
borrowed $500,000.
I know it's up to $550,000 now.
But I can only get $400,000.
Can you take it?
And a lot of times,
the bank will say yes
because the bank just
wants to get that cash.
Sometimes write it off,
and get it off their books.
Remember, I told you, you
gotta play by the rules
and understand the rules.
The homeowner cannot
get any money.
So the homeowner is basically
selling this house for nothing.
Why would a homeowner do it?
The headache of
the house, they're
getting it off their credit.
They're getting
rid of this house.
They're not getting those
phone calls anymore.
They're just selling it.
But if the bank had
to lose $150,000,
the homeowner
can't get anything.
Also, the homeowner could never
live in that house ever again.
Listen, they lost the home.
You're the new purchaser.
You can't rent
that home to them.
And that homeowner could never
own that house ever again.
And they're signing
papers that says
they're not going to do that.
Why?
Because if they do, it can
look like mortgage fraud.
It can look like they
set it up, defaulted,
had someone buy the
house just so they
can get this house for cheaper.
But a short sale
is a very, very,
very popular because there
are a lot of people, 30,000,
who are in foreclosure who
cannot afford their homes.
And they need to get out.
And the value of their home is
way lower than what they owe.
And a short sale is the
best option for them,
just to get out of the home.
And that's how you do it.
However, as investors, in
purchasing foreclosures,
I just advise you
to be very careful.
Work with someone who
is very knowledgeable.
Not all homeowners want to
be people who short sale.
Some homeowners are going
to try and try and try, just
like with a loan modification.
A loan modification is a program
that President Obama started
called the Making Home
Affordable program,
where if someone is
behind on their mortgage,
you can contact
the bank for help.
And you have to send in
pay stubs and tax returns
and letters and telling
them why you fell behind
and what is your action plan.
Some people are in foreclosure
because they had a divorce
or that have hospital bills,
or they lost their job.
And now, they are doing better.
And now, they want to catch up.
So they would apply
for a loan modification
requesting their mortgage loan
revamped, where they're either
asking for a lower monthly
payment that's manageable,
a lower interest rate, or taking
off some of the loan owed.
A lot of times, when that
doesn't work for them,
their next resort is
to do a short sale.
OK, in foreclosure, what is
often considered the hardest
consequence for the homeowner?
Damaging their credit,
deficiency judgment,
or losing their home?
Now, the answer is-- oh, sorry.
I can't go back.
The answer is a
deficiency judgment
because yes, they
lose their home.
But sometimes, they
can get a new home.
I know a couple who lost a home.
The wife wasn't
paying the mortgage.
The husband didn't know.
But I guess the
brighter side of it
was the mortgage was only
in the husband's name.
So now, the wife is going
to go get her own loan.
And they're going
to buy a new home.
Damaging your
credit-- many people
have damaged their credit and
have paid off those credit card
bills and redeemed
themselves and came back.
But a deficiency
judgement, just imagine
that if you owe $100,000
and you lost this house
and you don't have
this house anymore.
Now, you have the judgment
that's going to stick with you.
And you go get another job
and you fix your credit.
And then you have this judgment
on you that is sticking to you
that you have to pay off.
So that can be pretty bad.
We just went
through short sales.
Oh, excuse my typo.
The seller's agent-- I want to
talk about the seller's agent
that sometimes, as
investors-- which
I'm talking to you as
real estate investors.
As a buyer, you have to
understand that the seller may
have an agent working for them.
And I always use this example
like when the police say,
anything you say or do can
and will be held against you.
You want to be very careful when
you're purchasing an investment
property and the person has
an agent working for them
because you have to understand.
Real estate is very
difficult. I teach it.
It's a whole different language.
And if you don't
understand the language,
you can say something that
can hurt your negotiation.
So once they have
an agent, you want
to make sure you have an
agent too from the beginning
because that agent is
going to represent you.
That agent is going to be able
to talk the language for you.
I remember walking in with
one of my clients last year.
And I'm showing a house.
And the agent is
talking to my client.
And I turn to the agent,
and I said, please
do not talk to my client.
And he said, whoa, whoa.
You mean I can't say anything?
I said, no, absolutely not.
So he turned
around, and he says,
can you please tell your
client that the bathroom is
to the left?
[LAUGHTER]
And I said, the
bathroom is to the left.
And it seems ridiculous.
But you don't really
understand that when
you're purchasing real estate,
especially investment property,
the slightest thing you say
can hurt your negotiation,
absolutely hurt
your negotiation.
I remember showing a
house-- and I probably
gave this same example
last time I was here.
And the sellers had an agent.
But the agent never
came to the showing.
Silly, silly, agent.
And the lady, a
sweet old couple,
showing us around the house.
But while she's showing
me around the house,
she's complaining
about her knees.
Oh, my knees, my knees.
I can't go up these steps.
What did she basically tell us?
That she was very desperate to
sell this house, that any price
we give her, she will take,
because she can not take
going up and down these steps.
Now, her agent failed her
because her agent should
have came to the house, told
her and husband to sit down,
and he showed that house.
And we would have never
known why she was selling
or what her issues were
or how desperate she
was to sell this house.
So you have to remember,
as investors, as buyers,
the seller has a broker
representing them.
And they're going
to say anything.
And they're going to pull--
the slightest thing that they
say to you, believe it or not,
is to pull information from you
to get you to pay more money.
And the buyer's client,
you have to make sure
that you are represented.
Like I said, it
is very difficult.
I'm researching real
estate every single day.
I know what's up.
I now what's down.
I know the rules.
So you want to make sure
you're dealing with someone.
If you go into a courtroom,
the plaintiff has an attorney.
The defendant has an attorney.
You don't want to open your
mouth unless you're represented
because you don't know
all the legal terminology
they can be using.
And it's the same thing.
OK, you have to know your needs
and your wants as an investor.
You're all sitting
here right now.
I have some money.
I have credit.
I want to purchase some
real estate as investment.
foreclosures as an investment.
Well, what kind of foreclosures
do you want to buy?
What are your needs?
What are your wants?
How far do you want to travel?
Do you want to have
a property manager
or do you want to go collect
the rent every day yourself?
Do you want to buy this
house and live in it one day?
Or do you want to just
flip it and have it
just as an investment?
You have to understand what
your needs and your wants are.
And that's something
that you should
sit down with your
broker and go through,
how much capital you have.
How much money do
you want to spend?
You may have $200,000
sitting in your bank account,
but you don't want to
spend all that money.
You want to do some
of it in credit.
So those are the things
that you have to go through.
right?
You have to make sure if you
do going through a lender,
go through your
lender right away.
Talk with your lender.
Get your approval.
Money talks.
Right?
You could probably get a
cheaper deal if you used cash,
but you may not want
to use your cash.
And I'm trying to go a
little bit faster because I'm
looking at the time.
And I want to make sure
I get all your questions.
How to profit over real estate.
There's three ways
that you can profit.
So when you buy foreclosures
as an investment-- remember,
I spoke to you earlier
about your endgame?
You want to know
what your endgame is.
You're buying this property.
You don't want to
just sit there.
You want to make
sure you're making
money off of this property.
So you can do appreciation,
cash flow, and flipping.
Those of us who watch
those house shells on TV,
they talk about flipping.
They talk about these things.
Well, really, what are they?
OK, you see this person,
this home right here.
In 1930, somebody needed it.
1970, look at the value of how
it increased all these years.
Now, let's talk
about appreciation.
I'll move it over a little bit.
In 90 years, they bought this
house in 1920, for $35,000.
90 years later, $265,000.
Now, you may say, I'm not
going to be here for 90 years.
I'm just showing you how
the value of the property
has increased.
So you purchase a foreclosure
below market value,
this is what's going
to happen to you.
You also have flipping.
What is flipping?
You buy low, you sell high.
Remember, I told
you about your team.
Maybe you know someone who
does a little contracting.
Maybe on your day off, you
don't mind going in there
and painting the house and
fixing it up a little bit
yourself.
Look at this house that
they bought before.
They purchased it for $150,000.
They put $50,000
worth of repairs.
Their total acquisition
for it was $200,000.
And what did they do?
They sold it for $275,000.
$75,000 profit, just like that.
And this was a foreclosure.
Or this was a short sale
that someone couldn't buy.
Now, here's the thing.
Here's why you may
be able to compete.
Depending on how much cash you
have or the type of loan you
have, the regular
first-time home buyer
could not buy this home.
So that's beating out
some of your competition.
And you say, well,
Trisha, you just
told me I could
probably get a loan
to buy some of
these foreclosures.
Yes, you can.
But you will need to put
down a little bit more cash,
whereas a first-time home
buyer who has a family
and is purchasing these homes,
the amount of money, as low
as they're putting
down, they would not
be able to buy this home.
OK?
Also, cash flow.
Remember, this is one of the
foreclosures that we saw.
Believe it or not,
there are buildings
that have this many units
that are facing foreclosure.
So you purchase this home.
And you're looking at
cash flow every month.
So you didn't flip
it for that $75,000.
But you're collecting
rental income.
You may turn around
and say, well, I
don't want to ring
anyone's bell for rent.
That's a property
manager for you.
A property manager will be
the one to shovel the snow
and take out the trash
and collect the rent.
And they just send you
a check every month.
And at the end of the day,
you still have that building.
So when you want to
sell that building,
you can still make money
off of the appreciation
of that building.
And this is stuff, like I
said, I can individually
talk to you further about.
How do you increase the
value in this foreclosure?
You take this property that was
losing money, that had nothing,
and what do you do?
Maybe you put a laundromat
in the basement.
Maybe you put a storage
unit in the basement.
You can take your basement
and put storage units
where people can store
winter clothes in the summer.
They can store their bikes.
They can store Christmas
trees until they need it.
You can make money off of there.
Cellphone towers on the top.
If it's a corner building,
you can put billboards.
If you have parking
spaces-- these are all ways
that you can increase the
value of this home that
was foreclosing not too long
ago, that you picked up,
and the homeowner couldn't
afford it anymore.
And you were able to pick it up.
And then you calculate--
And this is something that we
have to go through, I told you,
where you have to analyze it.
What is the income that you're
getting on the property?
What are the expenses you're
getting on the property,
that you're paying
on the property?
What is your mortgage,
if you have a mortgage?
What are the taxes that
maintenance this insurance, OK?
You're netting $15,000 monthly
on this building, $180,000
yearly.
That's some people's salary.
And that's how much money
you're making on this property
that you picked up
next to nothing.
OK, what can you do next?
Attend classes, seminars,
workshops, lectures,
stay around like-minded
people, find a mentor,
learn the real estate market.
Where is there going to
be the next hot market?
I've predicted
quite a few markets
that we're going
to be coming up.
And they did,
especially, like I said,
I have agents who work
in all five boroughs,
and I'm licensed in a
couple other states.
But being born and
raised in Brooklyn,
there are neighborhoods
that I predicted before.
Williamsburg, I predicted
before it happened.
Redhook, I predicted
East New York, I predicted
was going to happen just
by looking at the markets,
understanding community,
and what's happening with
the mayor and the city.
You can understand where
you need to invest next.
Stay up to date on real
estate regulations and what's
going on.
You should have a real estate
professional helping you.
But you should also
understand these things.
And make sure you read.
OK?
This is my contact information
that if you need to get me,
if you have any other questions,
if you're interested in going
into foreclosure
investment and you
want to know more information
on it, we can do that.
With 10 minutes
left, I would like
to open it up for questions,
anything anyone may have.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Trisha.
Thank you are coming.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question is-- so
I have a couple of questions.
One is I didn't quite get what
was the downside of getting
foreclosed.
Was that second
one on the slide?
What exactly that meant.
And then, when you are
predicting-- so usually,
when we go buy houses and when
I bought a house in Astoria,
it was like we had to
line up with other buyers
and we only got two
minutes to see the place.
And we got to, from
our agent, the Haight,
the offers are
already piling up.
And sometimes even they
would call us and tell us,
the Haight's already sold.
Don't come.
So it was pretty diverse and
much like a seller's market,
they used to say,
especially in that area.
Very different if you go
deeper, like in Long Island.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: Right.
AUDIENCE: So, yeah,
in those cases,
it's more like hey,
how do you outbid
and the strategy
completely changes.
Even though they're
retiring, they just
want to get rid of the
house, the sellers,
it's so much lopsided, I found.
I'm not sure how the
negotiation strategy
work when you have only two
minutes to see the house.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: What
was your first question again?
AUDIENCE: My first question
was, what was the biggest
downside of getting foreclosed?
It was on your slide.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS:
Deficiency judgment.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
What exactly do
you mean by that.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: So
deficiency judgment, again,
is basically you have
a loan for $500,000,
but now, you can't
carry this home anymore.
And the house is worth $400,000.
So you sell the house, do
a short sale for $400,000.
But you still owe $100,000.
The bank is not going
to let you off scott
free with that $100,000.
So what they would do is they
would turn it into a judgment.
The bad part about
having the judgment
is now that this
judgment is sticking
with you-- the homeowner,
not you as the investor,
but the homeowner.
But it all goes based on
how the home is negotiated.
All banks won't give
a deficiency judgment.
It's how it's negotiated.
But you, as the investor, if
you're purchasing this home
from this homeowner through
a short sale or whatever,
you want to know
that they have that
and make sure that they
understand that they have that
because I truly
believe that there's
going to be a lot of people
who are going to file lawsuits
later on because the homeowner
just didn't know that they had
this judgment.
So now, they get a new job.
They fix their credit.
They start out fresh.
But they don't realize
that this judgment is still
attached to them.
So that, I think,
is a big downfall.
AUDIENCE: So they still
have to pay the 100k?
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS:
Yeah, and before, they
had to pay taxes
on the $100,000.
They lifted that.
And now, they're trying
to bring it back.
So yeah, absolutely,
that'll be a judgement
that'll be stuck to them.
But the bank looks at
their overall portfolio
because if they
own another house,
that may be more of
a reason why they
put that judgement
on them, because they
know that they can get it.
But if this person really
doesn't have anything,
they may not necessarily
put that deficiency judgment
on them.
As far as the other part,
two minutes to see a home,
I don't see how
that is possible.
I think it all goes back to who
is representing you as a buyer.
Right?
Whoever represents, and that
person who's representing you,
they have this thing
called all OCAR,
their fiduciary responsibility.
So if I'm representing
you, I'm obedient.
I'm loyal.
I have disclosure
confidentiality.
I'm fighting for you.
So the same way I
walk into that place
and tell the other people
they can't speak to you
is the same way I will
demand that we have more time
to see this property.
So it's all based on
who's representing you.
If I'm representing you,
I'm not out for my pocket.
I'm out for yours.
So that's very important.
Know who you're working with.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi, you mentioned
foreclosed houses at auction.
If you want to buy a house
at auction, but using
a loan from a bank, do you have
to get that loan ahead of time
before the auction so you
can put down the deposit
or pay for the home?
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS:
So the process--
you don't actually get the loan.
A loan is based
on having a house.
So part of a loan is on you.
But the actual loan
is based on the house.
So they're not going
to completely give you
the loan until you
have the house.
What you have to get
is a prequalification.
So you're going to bank.
And you're saying, hey, I want
to know how much am I qualified
to borrow.
And they're going to
base it on your credit,
your income, your history.
And they're going to turn
to you and say, OK, we'll
give you a loan for $600,000.
So that's money to
play around with.
You have up to $600,000
to do what you want.
Having that piece of paper is
to go to start shopping now.
So that's what you would need.
Now, once you find that house,
then you come back to them
and say, hey, I
found this house.
And now, they're going
to check that house
to make sure that house
matches what they will give you
the money for.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Trisha.
Thanks for coming.
So a few years ago
and also last year,
I tried to buy an investment
property in New York City.
And it was very
difficult because me
and a million other
people are trying
to buy the same property.
So it seemed easier to buy
property outside of New York,
like in Maryland or like those
lower areas or North Carolina
because it was easier
to get cash flow.
So in the whole of New York,
what types of properties
do you think are the
best for cash flow
or are the best for selling
later-- investment for cash
flow for selling them later.
And I'm including a commercial
buildings and parking lots.
Which do you think tend to
be better for cash flow?
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: Parking
lots, when I teach real estate,
they say parking lots
is considered dead money
because you're basically paying
taxes on a piece of land.
So buying a multi-unit property.
When you do an investment
for cash flow-- remember,
I told you appreciation,
cash flow, and flipping.
A one-family is good for
flipping because you're
buying it low and
you're selling it
to someone who wants to be
an end user, own and occupy.
For cash flow, you want
a two-family and up.
You could even do a
commercial property.
Just remember that when you're
buying a commercial property,
if you're taking out a loan,
you have to put a bigger
down payment on the property.
Now, how do you beat
out negotiation?
Beating out negotiation
is one, cash is king.
So if you do have cash,
you out beat the person
who does have a loan.
That doesn't mean
you can't get it.
You can get a foreclosure
or an investment property
with a loan.
But if there's a
lot of competition,
the people with the
cash are going to win.
Why are they going to win?
Because it's more
guaranteed that it will go.
Two, it's faster.
So that's how they're
looking at it.
The bank and the broker is
looking at the speed of it.
And three, if there is
something wrong, too much
wrong with the house, then
the bank may not give you
the loan because remember, it's
an investment for the bank too.
So if they're giving
you this money,
they want to make sure that
they're putting their money
into something that is OK.
If it has too many
issues, they want.
So I would say two-family in up.
A commercial is also OK because
you can rent out the store.
You can rent out the
apartments on top.
But you want to go
into neighborhoods
that are not developed
yet, but they're coming.
They're coming.
And when you see them, you have
to jump into them before they
become that neighborhood.
Like I said, East
New York in Brooklyn,
I predicted it was
coming a long time ago
because if you know
East New York, if anyone
is from Brooklyn, it has
the C Line and the A Line.
That's a straight train
line from East New York
straight to Manhattan.
Right, where I live in
Brooklyn, is a two-fare zone.
I got to jump on a bus, then
another bus, to the train,
just to get to the train,
whereas seeing the A right
there at your corner straight.
Another thing is East New
York has a lot of land left.
It's one of the
only neighborhoods
that had a lot of land.
The reason why I
knew it was going
to be the next neighborhood
is because I started
watching what they were doing.
They started planting
trees on the service lanes.
Now why you say, trees?
What does that have
to do with anything?
What does a nice, pretty
neighborhood look like?
A tree-lined block.
Now, the homes in
East New York, there
were a lot of foreclosures.
There were homes
going really cheap.
That's where I was
telling my clients,
this is where you need to buy.
Sure enough, that's the
neighborhood that's booming.
So anyone who did actually
buy in that neighborhood when
I was predicting it,
their dollar is going
to be very, very strong now.
So that's what you want to do.
You want to get
into a neighborhood
before it becomes the
next neighborhood.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for speaking
with us today.
Speaking of up and
coming neighborhoods,
do you have any
recommendations in the five
boroughs, Jersey
City, just this area?
TRISHA OCONA FRANCIS: Yeah,
Jersey City is becoming hot.
I know in the Bronx, the
Grand Concourse over there
is becoming pretty
hot over there.
You want to look
at neighborhoods
that have a lot of land.
That's one that you
want to look at, or have
a lot of warehousing.
You also want to check
this New York City
Department of Planning to
see where they're rezoning.
Where are they rezoning?
And the city zoners,
you can actually
sit down with the city
zoners and talk to them.
Another thing is you
want to look at--
and they're not
paying me, so I'm not
going to name their names.
But you want to look at some
of the chain stores, the coffee
shops, the restaurants.
Where are they going?
Because when you see
where they're going,
that means that they've
done their research
on that neighborhood.
So if you see them popping
up in certain areas,
those are areas you want to
be able to come in and buy
a house around.
Schools are a very good place to
buy around because-- colleges,
I mean, because when
the colleges are there,
a lot of times, people stay,
the graduates stay in that area.
So those are areas.
But also, a lot of times--
this mayor hasn't done it.
But I know Mayor
Bloomberg did it.
He put out plans of where
he's going to revitalize
those neighborhoods.
Also, if you find a
neighborhood that you're really
attracted to, go to their
local community board and sit.
They're free and they're
open to the public.
And you don't have
to be a member.
You don't even have to
live in that neighborhood.
You can just go to
their community board.
And you can hear
about what they're
planning on doing to the
neighborhood, what restaurants
are coming to that neighborhood.
And those are ways to
be able to tell as well.
They also have the
Public Safety Committee.
And you can look at
the level of crime
as well because when a
neighborhood is going
to be revitalized,
they go and they
make sure that the crime
is actually going down.
So that's and area as well
that you may want to go to.
So it's all about
just analyzing it.
East New York is still
very low in price.
And the value is
going to come up big.
So that's something that you
want to just look at as well.
Any other questions?
Well, I want to thank you all.
If you have any other
questions now or later,
you can always email me.
You can always call me.
That is my office number.
That is my company cell number
that you can call me on.
You can text that
number as well.
And if you have any
questions and you're
interested in investing
or if you just
want to sit down and go through
what your needs and wants
as an investor is-- you
may not want to invest now,
but you may want to
invest in two years or so,
and just want to get a feel of
how can you get on that path.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]